THAN EVER, PRO- AMERICA.
TONIGHT TAMMY BRUCE, CHARLIE
KIRK AND KIM STOSSEL.
LET’S GET TO THE POINT.
YOU KNOW HOW IT HOW I FEEL.
TWO WEEKS AGO I SAID WE NEEDED
TO FLATTEN THE CURVE NOT THE
ECONOMY.
I WARNED THE CURE COULD BE
WORSE THAN THE DISEASE BECAUSE
POVERTY KILLS.
DESPAIR KILLS.
OF COURSE THE VIRUS IS
DEADLY.
BUT SO IS THE SHUTDOWN.
[INAUDIBLE]
WE NEED TO HONOR THE VICTIMS
OF THE VIRUS AND FAMILIES WHO
HAVE LOST LOVED ONES.
IT’S TOTALLY WRONG FOR ANYONE
TO DISMISS OR MINIMIZE THE
PAIN AND SUP SUFFERING FROM
THE PANDEMIC OR TO IGNORE THE
FEDERAL STATE GUIDELINES, BUT
IT’S JUST AS WRONG TO DISMISS
OR MINIMIZE THE PAIN AND
SUFFERING FROM THE CORONAVIRUS
SHUTDOWN.
WELL, WE’VE ALREADY CONFIRMED
AT LEAST 9.9 MILLION AMERICANS
HAVE LOST THEIR JOB.
THAT DOESN’T EVEN INCLUDE THE
SELF-EMPLOYED AND THE
TRILLIONS IN RESCUE MONEY.
THAT WILL HAVE TO BE PAID FOR
AT SOME POINT.
IF YOU DIVIDE IT BETWEEN THE
AVERAGE TAXPAYER IT’S $45000.
THE PACKAGE WILL ONLY LAST A
FEW WEEKS.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
BUSINESSES GOING UNDER, MORE
IN SEPTEMBER AND OCTOBER WHEN
THERE IS THE REAL CRUNCH.
THEN BASED ON WHAT HAPPENED IN
THE GREAT RECESSION AND GREAT
DEPRESSION, FOR THOSE THAT
SHUTDOWN IT LOOKS LIKE IT WILL
BE WORSE THAN BOTH OF THOSE
COMBINED.
THE MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS, MASS
POVERTY WHICH LEADS TO LOWER
LIFE EXPECTANCY.
PAST EXPERIENCE PREDICTS THAT
MORE HUMAN LIFE WILL BE LOST
FROM THE SHUTDOWN THAN THE
MODELS PREDICT WILL BE LOST
FROM THIS VIRUS.
THOSE MODELS WILL PRESENTED TO
THE PRESIDENT AND ALL OF US.
THEY ARE THE REASON THE
SHUTDOWN WAS EXTENDED THROUGH
THE 30th OF APRIL.
WHAT THEY DIDN’T TELL YOU WAS
THIS FROM THE MAN WHO CREATED
THE MAIN MODEL.
>> THEY ASSUME THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING PLAYS IN PLACE
RIGHT THROUGH THE END OF MAY
TO GET THE TRAJECTORY WE SEE
AND WE HOPE THAT COULD BE AS
FEW AS 80000 DEATHS OR LESS.
>> THEY SAID THE SHUTDOWN WILL
LAST UNTIL APRIL 30 BUT IT
SEEMS LIKE IT’S ACTUALLY
JUNE 1, AT LEAST.
OUR LITTLE SHUTDOWN IS OVER
TWO.
THEY ARE DRIVING ONE OF THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT POLICY
DECISIONS IN THE HISTORY OF
THIS COUNTRY.
IT’S REASONABLE TO INVESTIGATE
THEM.
THE TWO-POINT TO MILLION DEATH
TOLL THAT WAS ON THE CHART IN
THE WHITE HOUSE BRIEFING ROOM
CAME FROM IMPERIAL COLLEGE
LONDON.
>> WE HAVE MORE COMPLETE
INFORMATION ABOUT THAT
DENOMINATOR THAT SUGGEST THAT
THE FATALITY RATE IS MUCH,
MUCH LOWER THAN 3.4%.
IT IS ACTUALLY PROBABLY MUCH
LOWER COMPARED TO THE .9% THAT
IS THE MAIN FIGURE THAT WENT
INTO SOME CALCULATIONS BY THE
WONDERFUL TEAM OF RESEARCHERS
IN IMPERIAL COLLEGE WHICH
PROBABLY OVERESTIMATED THE
EXACT INFECTION OF FATALITY
RISK.
>> THE PROJECTION OF A HUNDRED
THOUSAND TO 240,000 DEATHS,
EVEN WITH A TOTAL NATIONAL
SHUTDOWN LASTING UNTIL AT
LEAST JUNE THE FIRST.
THE FACTORS THAT WENT INTO
THAT CALCULATION INCLUDE DATA
FROM ITALY WHICH HAS ALSO BEEN
QUESTIONED BY
EPIDEMIOLOGISTS.
>> IT WOULD NOT BE SURPRISING
IF IN SOME LOCATIONS WE HAVE
CURRENTLY REACHED INFECTION
RATES OF 20 OR EVEN 30% BUT
THIS IS STILL A BICS GOOD
AVENUE.
IF THAT’S THE CASE THEN YOU
NEED TO CORRECT THE INFECTION
FATALITY RATE OR CASE FATALITY
RATE FOR ITALY THAT SEEMS TO
BE VERY HIGH BY A VERY LARGE
FACTOR.
IT COULD BE A CORRECTION OF
100 FOR EXAMPLE THAT NEEDS TO
BE APPLIED.
>> OKAY, LET’S IGNORE THE
PUBLIC HEALTH EXPERTS
QUESTIONING THE DATA AND TAKE
THEM AT FACE VALUE.
A WORST-CASE SCENARIO WAS
PRESENTED LAST WEEK AND WILL
BE DWARFED BY THE LONG-TERM
HUMAN TOLL PARAMORE HUMAN LIFE
ACROSS A MUCH BROADER RANGE
WILL BE LOST.
IN THE UK, THE GOVERNMENT IS
MODELING THE HEALTH IMPACT OF
THE SHUTDOWN AS WELL AS THE
VIRUS.
OUR GOVERNMENT SHOULD DO THAT
HERE AND BE CLEAR THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EXPERTS ARE SAYING THAT
WHEN THE SHUTDOWN IS LIFTED
THE VIRUS WILL COME BACK SO
SHUTDOWN REMAINS THE ONLY
POLICY.
WE WOULD NEED MANY MORE FOR AT
LEAST ANOTHER YEAR UNTIL WE
GET A VACCINE.
THE PUBLIC HEALTH EXPERTS FEEL
IT’S ANNOYING AND INCONVENIENT
BUT WE HAVE TO ACCEPT IT.
IF YOU LOSE YOUR JOB AND YOUR
FAMILIES RELYING ON IT FOR A
ROOF OVER THEIR HEAD, THAT’S
NOT ANNOYING, IT’S
TERRIFYING.
IF YOUR BUSINESS COLLAPSES
AFTER YOU’VE PUT YOUR LIFE
INTO IT AND SECURED YOUR HOME
AGAINST IT, THAT’S NOT
INCONVENIENT, THAT’S A
DISASTER.
IT’S SOMETHING FROM WHICH YOU
MAY NEVER RECOVER.
IF WE TRULY WANT TO SAVE
LIVES, ALL LIVES, THEN WE NEED
TO DO TWO THINGS.
SLOW THE SPREAD BUT SPEED THE
SHUTDOWN.
IT MUST END AS SOON AS SAFELY
POSSIBLE.
THAT MEANS WE NEED A BETTER
ANTIVIRUS POLICY THAT WE HAVE
RIGHT NOW.
LAST WEEK I SAID OPEN WHERE
POSSIBLE, CLOSE WERE
NECESSARY.
SHUTDOWN DO SLOW THE SPREAD.
LOOK AT THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
THE BAY AREA WHICH HAD THE
NATION’S FIRST STAY-AT-HOME
ORDER IN NEW YORK CITY.
SO, RIGHT NOW, IN THE ABSENCE
OF A BETTER ANTIVIRUS POLICY,
IT IS NECESSARY TO SHUT THINGS
DOWN EVERYWHERE AND THAT
INCLUDES UTAH, WYOMING,
OKLAHOMA, ARKANSAS, NEBRASKA,
NORTH DAKOTA, SOUTH DAKOTA
IOWA, SOUTH CAROLINA WHERE
THERE ARE NO STATEWIDE
STAY-AT-HOME ORDERS.
TONIGHT I’M ASKING THOSE
GOVERNORS, INCLUDING A GREAT
FRIEND OF THE SHOW, KIM
REYNOLDS IN IOWA TO PUT IN
PLACE A STAY AT HOME ORDER AT
LEAST UNTIL THE STAY-AT-HOME
GUIDELINES.
OF COURSE THAT WILL TAKE A
HIGH TOLL IN THOSE STATES IN
OUR COUNTRY.
JOBS, BUSINESSES, LIVELIHOODS
AND LIVES.
REMEMBER THIS IS NOT A CHOICE
BETWEEN PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE
ECONOMY BETWEEN LIVES AND
MONEY.
THE SHUTDOWN COSTS LIVES TWO.
THE PRESIDENT KNOWS THIS AND
THAT’S WHY HE ORGANIZED THE
BIGGEST AND QUICKEST RESCUE
PACKAGE FOR AMERICA’S WORKERS,
FAMILIES AND SMALL BUSINESSES
WE’VE EVER SEEN.
EVEN THOUGH THEY’VE DELETED,
THERE STILL SOME BAD THINGS IN
THERE.
I WANT TO FOCUS ON ONE THAT
COULD HAVE SERIOUS
CONSEQUENCES.
THE SMALL BUSINESS PAYCHECK
PROTECTION PROGRAM AND
UTILITIES FOR EIGHT WEEKS.
BUT, THE AMOUNT THAT SMALL
BUSINESSES CAN GET IS BASED ON
THEIR PAYROLL COST.
ONLY RENT ISN’T TAKEN INTO
ACCOUNT AT ALL.
THAT IS CRAZY.
RENT IS A HUGE COST FOR THOSE
COMPANIES.
SO MANY ENTREPRENEURS HAVE
TOLD ME YOU’VE GOT TO GET THE
PRESIDENT TO CHANGE THIS.
MANY LANDLORDS RIGHT NOW ARE
DOING THE DECENT THING AND
SAYING YOU CAN MISS PAYMENTS
FOR THE NEXT TWO OR THREE
MONTHS BUT THOSE LANDLORDS
HAVE BILLS TO PAY TWO.
THEY ARE GOING TO ADD IT BACK
ONTO RENT PAYMENTS IN A FEW
MONTHS.
SMALL BUSINESSES WITH TIGHT
MARGINS WON’T DIVIDE THAT.
THE WORST OF THE TOLL IS THE
JOB CRASH BUT BECAUSE OF THIS
PROBLEM BECAUSE OF THE
PAYCHECK PROTECTION PROGRAM,
SMALL BUSINESSES WILL BE GOING
BUST IN AUGUST, SEPTEMBER,
OCTOBER JUST WHEN THE ECONOMY
IS SUPPOSED TO COME ROARING
BACK.
STEVE MNUNCHIN HAS BEEN GREAT
IN THIS CRISIS BUT ALL THAT
WORK WILL BE FOR NOTHING IF
SMALL BUSINESSES COLLAPSE
BECAUSE OF THIS TECHNICAL
PROBLEM.
WE COULD SEE THE PRESIDENT ARE
TOTALLY FOCUSED ON WINNING THE
WAR AGAINST THE CORONAVIRUS.
IN THE MIDDLE EAST WE GOT
BOGGED DOWN IN AN ENDLESS WAR
BECAUSE NO ONE KNEW THE
OBJECTIVE OR HADDOCK PLAN FOR
ACHIEVING IT.
WITH CORONAVIRUS IT SHOULD BE
CLEAR.
IT’S NOT REALISTIC OR
ACHIEVABLE TO SAY NO ONE
SHOULD EVER GET INFECTED.
THE GOAL SHOULD BE TO STOP OUR
HOSPITALS FROM BECOMING
OVERWHELMED.
THE IMMEDIATE TASK IS TO SLOW
THE SPREAD AND SEARCH OUR
CAPACITY.
THE EXTRA ICU BEDS, THE
VENTILATORS, THAT IS
HAPPENING.
THAT IS TODAY’S BATTLE, BUT
IT’S NOT HOW WE WIN THE WAR
AND NEITHER IS SHUTDOWN.
WHEN YOU LIFT THE SHUTDOWN THE
VIRUS COMES BACK.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WILL NOT
PUT UP MUCH LONGER BEING TOLD
THERE’S NO ALTERNATIVE.
THEY WANT TO KNOW THEIR
LEADERS ARE WORKING ON A MORE
SUSTAINABLE ANTIVIRUS POLICY.
THEY UNDERSTAND WE NEED TO
SLOW THE SPREAD BUT WHAT THEY